let's go to Anibal from Guatemala
welcome to the program
Hi how are you I'm doing well
okay okay I have a little question
um how did you deal with negationist
uh I am talking about but well in
Guatemala we had a really big world a
civil war some years ago and even today
I have some codex features
who are talking about how the Glorious
Army of Guatemala
who committed genocide
was too good for us and they keep us
away from the Communists and thanks to
God
all of us are okay now um we are not
Venezuela
it's really
ah you think they just deny basic
reality yep
um and even if I say well maybe it's not
God you can see a lot of religious
groups have
um look for the evidence of this and
everything uh they say something like oh
but you know they were just catalicks or
juice uh sorry I don't know what to say
it in English sweetas Jesuits
um yes yes
um or everything is the fault of the
Masons and illuminatis yeah
it's really bad yeah I I don't when
people are just straight up you know
they don't live in in reality it's very
difficult you know there's an example
from Argentina as well where of course
there was as many people know there was
this Falklands War that took place as
they're known in Argentina and the other
day you know the
I I don't want to pretend that there's
literally only one interpretation of
every detail but I think it's hard to
it's hard to deny that that was a
completely idiotic wrong-headed move uh
in Argentina to distract from the
horrors of the military dictatorship and
it it was just an absurd thing for
Argentina to be doing and the other day
when it was like the the anniversary
um I saw a news piece that basically
like they just brought in a few veterans
who fought for Argentina in that
conflict and they acted like it was you
know World War II fighting against the
Nazis as opposed to a completely
contrived and wrong-headed
um a propaganda conflict and it's like
if you if that's the alternate reality
you're living in I I don't know that we
can even really talk you know I mean
it's just so disconnected from the the
truth
yes I know let me recommend you a really
great movie uh La Llorona from Jairo
Bustamante not the one about the
aquarium Brothers
okay I will check it out it was
absolutely amazing is even went to the
show list short list of the Oscars well
about that even or president Alejandro
yamate is talking about how how Jewish
Aid is making claims and helping people
um to create an agenda for indigenous
and it all feels so wrong I mean uh so
there are like a
republican idea in Guatemala and they
are talking about how this group of
indigenous people who commit Human
Sacrifice uh are now going to
um
nobody's saying that
um you you just watch
um is obvious
um home every touch Foundation is
talking with Alejandro yamate and
everything is so obvious then they are
just making the claim about critical
race Theory but in Guatemala interesting
I don't know enough about that but it
sounds interesting and I will research
it I'm pretty sure there are just
Republicans who are helping Alejandro
yamate because they want to use these
idea of critical race Theory everywhere
right
um yeah when all you have is a hammer
everything everything looks like a nail
listen an evil I do have to let you go
but quick question what I know nothing
about the cuisine of your country what
is a what is a typical food item in
Guatemala
oh there are a lot
um soups are some of the greatest things
and maybe it means intactical red
um soup it is amazing is made of chilies
um beef or maybe chicken it's amazing
all right very good I appreciate the
call thank you
you're welcome all right there is Anibal
from Guatemala let's go next where are
we going next let's go to Logan
from San Jose California Logan welcome
can you hear me all right sort of yeah
there's something weird going on but I
think we can we can make it work
yeah oh God
so I'm gonna have to let you go it's
it's not workable the audio just it went
it went very very bad completely nuclear
and and horrifying let's go to Shelley
from Indiana Shelley welcome
hi David my question today was about the
um
uh student loan forgiveness okay
um so with all of the with all of the
people that are against it it seems like
they
[Music]
they used it
um and would there be in a lawsuit
against it right now
um my question is at what point do these
lawsuits that they're encouraging end up
costing more money than it would have to
actually
supported the program I don't know the
answer to that I mean I think the
lawsuits
the lawsuits would have to go on for a
really long time and be
multi-jurisdictional and be very
expensive before they would approximate
the cost of the student debt relief but
I don't even know that that's
necessarily the the best argument to
make for why this doesn't make any sense
it's remember this student loan debt
forgiveness would be economically
stimulative it would free up money
rather than being paid for interest on
loans to be injected into the economy
into businesses of all sorts of
different kinds so you're you're not
making your argument is fine which is
the lawsuits to fight the Forgiveness
cost money and at some point that's
going to add up to a whole bunch of
money it's also that the student loan
debt forgiveness would be very good
demand side stimulus and good for the
economy
yes yeah you're right I agree
um I guess the other question is then
what what do they actually do with the
interest that they're already getting on
from all of these levels and what it's
like for all of the years of of the of
the interest that they've already get
God wanted that to have ultimately paid
for it
I'm not sure I understand you're saying
what should happen in the context of the
Forgiveness with already paid interest
well I'm saying like where when they do
collect the interest you know because
I've been paying on my school loans for
20 years right so you're figuring you
know oh it's just it's just it's profits
or it goes back if they're government
loans then it goes back into the
government coffers I mean it's just like
I need Debt Service
right so then at that point wouldn't
there be like a surplus to where they
could just paint you know what I mean
where it could just be paid for to begin
with
at this point in time so it's like all
of these loans overall they see all
these oh you're saying just pay off the
current loans with the interest that
they've already collected over the years
correct oh I see yeah I mean that money
has been spent of course but you're I
the idea of what you're saying is not
crazy which is a ton of money has
already been made on the interest on
these loans but what happened to it it
was spent on other stuff is the answer
Shelly
right okay all right well thank you very
much I appreciate your time I appreciate
it things are okay in Indiana
oh yeah they're really good I can't
honestly I can't tell if you're kidding
uh no it's been right now I'm I'm
actually kind of nervous about it
Tuesday yeah you know because I mean
it's a good state so you know if you
didn't know what you shouldn't expected
but
um you can always hope for the most and
no doubt you will be voting I'm sure
absolutely all right Shelly always great
to hear from you thank you all right
thank you David all right there goes
Shelly in Indiana voting that's what you
call a likely voter she's she's gonna
vote I could just tell she's going to
vote you can count on Shelley's vote uh
that does it for calls today we're going
to go to a break I appreciate every
single one of you who has signed up on
the YouTube channel recently approaching
2 million subscribers I appreciate
everyone who called in even those I did
not get to
but we will take calls again very very
soon